ariana syed who has now settled outside
of afghanistan she's an afghan pop star
and women's rights activist advocating
for the rights of women in her home
country and was on one of those
evacuation flights out of kabul in
recent days ariana joins us now from los
angeles ariana good afternoon to you
good luck to you um
what a extremely worrying and difficult
journey uh you must have had to leave
afghanistan in the last few days given
the the fraught atmosphere the chaotic
things we could see at the airport tell
us what you had to do and what it was
like to try and leave kabul
well uh i've been through a very
horrifying experience trying to leave
afghanistan and escape it was not easy
at all for me because i'm a well-known
face as you said in afghanistan and also
the fact that i've been a women's rights
activist and i've openly talked against
taliban for many many years now so i i
have been a direct target and to get out
of afghanistan in a situation like that
was not easy at all i had to go through
a few taliban checkpoints even during
the night trying to escape and get to
the airport and get to the u.s army base
uh with my fiance and uh let's put it
this way i have i think it's it's a
miracle that i was able to do that and
i'm quite grateful
but my heart goes out to all the women
and children and millions of people who
are left behind in afghanistan and they
have nowhere to go
yeah give us an idea of the desperation
outside that airport because for us here
in the uk and worldwide watching those
scenes we're not actually there but
those scenes are going to stay with us
for a long time tell us about the people
you saw there the stories you heard
every everyone with the same aim
escaping the taliban
i actually saw everything in person i
wasn't on the ground when all that was
happening
you know uh we attempted twice to go to
the airport uh because initially on the
15th of august i had a flight
unfortunately the flights couldn't take
off because the the airplane that we
were booked on was filled with with like
thousands of people in it uh with you
know people with guns inside inside the
uh airplane and unfortunately the
pilots had to run away and the plane
didn't take off the next day we
attempted to come to the airport same
story uh you know thousands of people
children crying it was a disaster it was
absolutely disastrous
and um
it's it's so unfortunate you know that
people have to go through that and
obviously you know there's one more
thing that i want to add that you know
as i said that was one of those lucky
ones with a uk passport that i was able
to get out i mean those thousands of
people who are trying to get out and
they have they cannot do that i just
feel bad for them
and you know i feel like the world has
led us down unfortunately
what are your fears for women and girls
under the new taliban regime they are
presenting a moderate face at the moment
saying that they will
preserve the rights of women and girls
they will still be able to enjoy an
education they will still be able to go
to work
you're shaking your head you don't
believe a word of it
no
i personally do not believe a word of it
i don't trust them for what we have
experienced with taliban what they did
to women in afghanistan 20 years ago
was
historic and it will stay whether it was
horror
so basically i also want to say that i
think they're portraying this space just
to be
able to be recognized by the world and
what is the guarantee that once they're
recognized they will hold on to the
world
uh
so
this this is why i think they're doing
this and i i do not believe them they
they will just turn back to uh who they
were or who do they are uh i just i just
don't believe a word i hope i mean i
hope that what they're saying they will
actually act upon it and i hope that the
world if they reach some kind of a deal
with them i hope that they will hold
them accountable for what they're saying
right now about women
arianna you talk about the horror that
women and girls faced under the taliban
that is well documented and it is a
frightening picture
for women and girls in that country to
revisit there are some girls who have
grown up not knowing the taliban and
what a shock they are going to face if
they revert back to their own ways you
say the world has let afghanistan down
what would you say to world leaders
we're about to hear from the prime
minister boris johnson we're about to
hear from the u.s president joe biden
they met with other g7 leaders today to
talk about afghanistan what do you want
to hear from them
uh three things i would like to say i
understand that they obviously cannot
take the whole country out there's like
30 something million people in
afghanistan and uh it's nice of them
that they're trying to get all the
american citizens and uk citizens out
but i want to say how can we forget
about the millions of people
who are right in afghanistan and they
have nowhere to go secondly i hope that
they can put some kind of pressure on
pakistan because we firmly believe that
all the problem in afghanistan is
because of pakistan because that's where
taliban get their trainings done that's
where they get their support and funds
from and i believe that if if the world
stop funding pakistan
maybe our problems will be less in
afghanistan and there will be less
terrorism in afghanistan i mean what was
what was the reason for the world to go
to afghanistan if we try to remember 20
years ago they went to afghanistan
saying that we are trying to get rid of
al qaeda and we're going to get rid of
taliban but 20 years later we're back in
the same spot and nothing has been done
even though there was american soldiers
lives that was lost in afghanistan uk
soldiers were
you know sacrificed in afghanistan and
after spending millions and trillions of
dollars in afghanistan nothing has been
done and they would just i cannot
believe that they would just leave us
and just go just like that overnight so
it's really shocking to me i just hope
that they can sit down together and you
know uh and and and find some kind of a
solution to bring peace in afghanistan
so that the people don't even have to
leave
ariana thank you so much for speaking to
us